because
welcome to the talk on rounding we are
low dimensional embeddings uh this is a
talk for
itcs23 I'm Mark Braverman and this is
Joint work with darminster
so uh we'll talk about
um
the the main goal of this paper is to
develop new techniques
around low dimensional embeddings
and we recover results internal
repetition spectral partitioning and
maxcat algorithms which should be our
random example today
um so the results were known but we
obtained new proofs that are arguably
simpler or at least more Elementary
they don't require the use of linear
algebra to to recover the results
so uh the main goal is to develop new
techniques with the hope that they'll
find more applications down the line
so I'll run an example today is Max cut
and uh
refinements of the government's
Williamson algorithm so what is the max
cut problem the max cat problem is we
are given a graph G and we want to an
undirected graph and we want to
partition its vertex set into two parts
so such that the fraction of edges that
cross the cut between the two parts is
maximized
so it's a well-known anti-hard problem
and so the goal is an approximation goal
and the regime will work in today is one
where there is a Max an almost perfect
Max cut so the graph is nearly bear Pi
bipartite even though not quite so the
max cut value is close to one
so let's say the max cut value is 1
minus Delta and we really want to find a
large cut ideally we only want to
pay a constant Delta so find a card that
misses c times Delta of the edges so
we'll see when it's possible
so uh the best known result in this area
is the government's Williamson algorithm
so it does the following it Maps the
vertex that V into the unit sphere in
some high dimensional space
each vertex is assigned a vector
and we convert
uh the optimization from the max cut
problem into its continuous relaxation
where we try that edges correspond to
vectors that are almost opposite of each
other
so uh the ideal solution would map all
the vertices in V1 to plus one on all
the vertices in V2 to -1 so this for
every age this would be four and we want
this is the continuous version of this
and this version actually is polytime
solubles using semi-definite magic of
semi-definite programming it's important
to point out that there is this Square
we'll get back to it later
uh and as I said there is an integer
solution that just the one-dimensional
one so the continuous Solutions at least
has at least as good a value as the
discrete one
and
um
uh but the continuous solution might
look nothing like
the a neat solution that maps have a V1
to to One Direction and V2 to the
opposite it could be something that
spreads them over the entire sphere
and
uh so so we are given a set of vectors
that are kind of spread out so the
distances between uh corresponding to
edges are pretty large and we can get a
cut an actual partition using hyper
plane around and so it's a very simple
idea we pick a random hyperplane
and anything on one side becomes one
part of the cotton and anything on the
other side becomes the other part of the
cut so that's hyper plane rounding
and and one another way to view this
process is that we first project
uh vectors from RN to R randomly
so those X's get mapped to points
between minus one and one after some
proper normalization and then
we
map every all the positive numbers to
plus one and all the negative points to
minus one it's just an equivalent way of
doing hyperplane partition but it will
be
a useful way to think about it later on
another equivalent way we could think of
first it doesn't matter we could first
project into R2 and then pick a random
line and and cut the points this way so
again it's equivalent
so the and the question is can we do
better either in terms of rounding find
a better rounding or maybe analyze
rounding better than in the classical
analysis and
there is one example where we were from
about 10 years ago where it turned out
that you can do better than hyperplane
rounding so
um it's a it could be a topic of a
different lecture but so the example is
the growth in the constant so
it's it's a classical problem and
Analysis we're given a real Matrix a and
the goal is to find plus minus one
numbers that maximize this uh quadratic
form and this is also known to be NP
hard like all of those commentary
problems once again this problem can be
relaxed
into a semi-definite version where
instead of uh numbers where we are
talking about unit vectors so vectors of
length
y of L 2 x 1 and instead of products we
take inner products
and so this is an sdp relaxation and
the integrality gap of this relaxation
is known as the growth in the constant
and it's important in analysis and in
adjacent areas
and
so they can
a naturalist DP relaxation I didn't tell
you exactly how to do the sdp
uh
and plus rounding and projecting onto
the line which is the the analog of the
one-dimensional uh round and for that
problem gives an a certain upper bound
that was actually a conjecture to be
optimal but turned out so not
surprisingly to be sub-optimal and uh
the Improvement came by instead of
projecting into
uh instead of doing a hyperplane cut so
which corresponds to project into R2
and the cutting into the line it turns
out that you can do better by just doing
a different partition so you use some
other partition that's not it it
correlates with hyperplane but it's not
a hyperplane and it turns out that just
doing this gives you a better
approximation ratio so there is
sometimes uh something to be gained by
taking this perspective of instead of we
have a bunch of vectors that come from a
seven different programming solution
instead of
um
projecting them
onto a line essentially or cutting them
through hyperplane sometimes it's
productive to project even into R2 and
do something more clever with the
resulting vectors and of course by there
is no way that this is the best
algorithm but this already gives an an
interesting Improvement to the Natural
uh hyperplane partition algorithm
so going back to Gorman's Williamson
so we are given
a collection that maximizes a collection
of vectors that maximizes the distances
between uh between vectors that
correspond to edges
we want to partition so we basically
want to map those X axes into plus minus
one that maximize the cut size so we
want the same problem but all the
vectors are numbers they're either plus
or minus one
and it's easier to think about because
we are in the regime where most vectors
are almost opposite of each other it's
actually easier to think about it in
terms of complements so we start with
something where instead of taking the
difference we take the sum and this sum
is very small so x i is typically very
close to negative x j
and we want
to make
the expectation of the sums of the plus
minus one labels as small as possible
ideally as small as Delta
um
so let's take the 2D views so we first
project so
uh in so the one give you is we project
the axis onto the real line and then
once they're on the real line there is
not that much we can do we just take the
positives to plus one and the negative
to minus one but let's make the extra
step of projecting them
into the two-dimensional space so we
Project X I into y i on the unit circle
so by first projecting to the 2D plane
and then normalizing so now instead of a
bunch of vectors and some high
dimensional space we have a bunch of
vectors in on the unit circle and the
actual solution uses the 3D sphere but
it's easier to on the board of course
it's easier to show it with 2D and the
principle is exactly the same
okay so imagine that this step actually
didn't cost as much so we know that
projected into plus minus 1 does cause a
significance in the gravity Gap but for
now suppose that projected into the unit
sphere actually didn't cause any
problems and the expected Solutions the
expected value of the solution of the
Y's is not much worse only a constant
worse than the solution on the axis so
basically instead of a bunch of unit
vectors and I run we got a bunch of unit
vectors in the plane
so we have a good enough solution there
so now we want a card that separates as
few pairs as possible of the form y i
minus y j where I J is an edge that
that's the goal
so
the anatomy of the integrality gap of
the government's Williamson algorithm
is like this so we have y i and negative
y j that are distance D from each other
so if you take a lot a random line
through the origin the probabilities
that it will separate by a negative y j
the probability of the bad event is
about D so the expected contribution of
this Edge to the bad event is d
but the contribution to the Badness of
the continuous solution is only D
Squared so this is this two here really
makes a span this is real
uh it's not an artifact of the proof
there is an actual integrality Gap in
this semi-definite program so it's it
has to happen so the continuous solution
page this Square while the discrete
solution with this rounding will end up
in D which is a lot more when this small
the penalty ratio can is can be as is as
high as one over d
and for a solution whose value is Delta
so it it's possible that the typical
distance is root Delta so that the
distance square is Delta so and this
penalty can be as high as 1 over Delta
so the words in the worst case we get an
uh a gap
for instead of Delta we get
a car cut of value 1 minus root Delta
only so that's the value of the cut we
get and then and under the unique games
conjecture it's actually optimal so it's
it's this is the best we can do for
General graphs without break into any
games conjecture
it's a
and we know that with this emptiness and
programming program we cannot do that
it's possible that there is a different
program for example a higher SOS some
Square hierarchy level that actually
breaks the ugc this way but this is
for future work
um
so for General graphs there is not
nothing better we can do but we can do
better on small set expanders which is
uh the main subject of the paper of the
technical results on the paper are new
results for small set expanders so what
is a small set expander so an undirected
graph G
so
it's a regular undirected graph J that
set
for a set of vertices its expansion is
the fraction of edges that leave the set
so those are the edges that start to
test and leave it versus all the edges
that start in s so it's a ratio between
zero and one the set is expanding
the set is a gamma expander if every
small every set that's less than half
the vertices is expanded of course
um if s is V then by definition it
cannot be expanding but an expand a
gamma expander is is a set where all is
a graph for all sets
that are less that do not contain the
majority of the vertices expand by at
least gamma and the small set expander
it has a second parameter Epsilon such
that
sets large sets may not be expanding but
a subset of vertices of size at most
Epsilon V
must have an expansion with this gamma
so now we have two parameters so a
proper expander is a half gum expander
uh so that's the definition
and so uh how can we do better let's go
back so now the graph is embedded into
into the unit circle
and sets with fewer than Epsilon V
vertices expand because it's a small set
expander so let's sketch and improve and
improved rounding algorithm for
governance Williamson sdp
so we partitioned the circle into 10
over Epsilon segments each of uh size
Epsilon over 10.
so most segments do not contain that
many vertices so we call a segment heavy
if it contains more than Epsilon V
vertices
but there are at most
one over Epsilon heavy segments so most
segments are not heavy and in particular
instead of cutting randomly we can cut
randomly and make sure not to not touch
those heavy segments so we
a random card that avoids those heavy
segments still in expectation cuts
the same number of edges not not much
more edges than one that doesn't have
this constriction because this
restriction
only affects 10 percent of the trials
anyway
so we can cut randomly while avoiding
those red red segments
and now when we cut the light segment so
the bad things that I described earlier
doesn't happen because a light segment
has to expand which means that the edges
in the light segment have to travel a
large distance so I have certain
subtitles under the rug but
uh a light segment will have a lot of
edges leaving it so the typical Edge out
of the light segment will have a length
of something like Epsilon over 10.
which means that the penalty ratio that
we have to pay D is is on the order one
over Epsilon and not on the order of
root Deltas before and Epsilon here you
should think of as a constant while
Delta is a tiny parameter so
for a light segment so we avoided
cutting densely populated parts of the
graph and for a non-densely populated
this expansion property tells us that
the edges that we do cut typically are
long enough such that the penalty from
going from the ldp level
and that's where the gain is and I'm
sweeping some details on the drug but
this is basically the picture that
captures the entire proof
so um
there is some a little more details to
take care of to make sure that not all
edges that leave the segment are small
but this won't happen unless or
there's it's it's possible to analyze it
with some charging argument but that's
basically it
so instead of paying root Delta we pay
Epsilon and so we get a cut of size 1
minus order of Delta over Epsilon which
is better than root Delta if we think of
Epsilon as a
significantly larger than Delta
so
to give intuition for why projecting
into low dimensional spaces here was a
useful thing to do let's consider two
alternatives to this of course it's a
correct theorem so there are many ways
to prove it and actually as I'll mention
those results have been known before
or follow from previous works but uh why
did this analysis why doesn't it work
directly so we could instead of
projecting to low dimensional space
stick with the high dimensional
space and try to avoid just Define heavy
or dense clumps and try to avoid them
and the simple answer is that we did use
low dimensional geometry in our analysis
specifically
it's a property of low dimensional
spaces that if you have a ball of radius
Epsilon a random line easily avoids it
so or if you have one over Epsilon balls
of radius
Epsilon over 10
the the fact that it's easy to avoid is
the property of low dimensional geometry
in high dimension somehow this doesn't
work alternatively
um
what does the game
uh vis-a-vis the original uh Judah Gomez
Williamson rounding
um so most of the loss it turns out
happens when you project from R2 to R1
so I I said that we did our two
projection not our three just to make
the the picture nicer but so here is uh
just a simple calculation shows that if
you take a segment x i x j of length d
and so it's sdp cost is d square and you
project it so if you project it onto a
zero the the two points plus minus one
with the natural projection so your
projector onto R and then
um normalize Twitter plus one or minus
one the expected
uh cost is on the order of D so the sdp
cost was this square but you cut this
edge with probability D and this is the
root Delta
onto S1 if you do what we described here
in in the previous slides if you project
onto R2 and then normalize it into the
unit circle you essentially you lose
some log 1 over D so you're almost there
but uh the first order factor is D
Squared so you recover most of the loss
because for the
when you project onto R1 your second has
a pretty good chance of containing zero
but when you project onto R2 it's much
harder for your segment to be close to
zero and when you projection to r3s is
this probability becomes insignificant
so actually the expected
costs when you project into R3 and
normalize
you only pay a constant Factor so this
is potentially a fun fact
to know that essentially in many of
these sdp scenarios without loss of
generality you can assume your vectors
live in our R3 if you don't care about
constants
so that's uh that's why that's the gain
from going to R2 or R3
so just
to summarize let me State the results
so again the definition this is just a
reminder of the definition
uh Epsilon gamma small set expander uh
satisfies that for all sets of with the
most Epsilon fraction of the vertices
have Edge expansion of at least gamma so
they uh at least gamma fraction of the
edges have to leave the set so the
generic results for Max cut
so we start with a graph with Max cut of
at least one minus Delta
and uh with us with the government's
Williamson without any assumptions on
the graph we can find uh a cut of value
1 minus c times root Delta and this is
optimal under the unique games
conjecture so improving this Delta to
the half would break the ugc
so what we get is a cut of Delta and
some parameter factors so Delta over
Epsilon and the factor that depends on
gamma so we we think of gamma as a
constant that small cells do expand
and this also follows from the spectral
approach uh and the references are in
the paper
and very similar basically the square uh
the the exact same square that follows
from converting from L to square to L1
appears in many different places
and uh so in in those other places we
are able to get similar results with
similar techniques uh on small set
expanders so specifically triggers an
equality and parallel repetition in game
so I won't Define those in detail but
I'll just State the results and
in case
uh
for completeness and they're also in
so for Checkers inequality uh
we start with uh
a graph with a small spectral Gap and
the inequality implies that there is a
set with uh there is a sparse cut there
is a set with expansion less than square
root Delta and this is tight for example
for the cycle graph
and for small set expense the expanders
again this half can be
eliminated uh
and replace with something that depends
on
um
on Epsilon and Gamma it also follows
from previous words from the spectral
approach
and uh for for those familiar with the
repetition theorem
uh the uh let's say for Unique games we
have a game PSI on a graph G
and the better repetition theorem tells
us that we if we started the game whose
value is 1 minus Delta so it's strictly
less than one if you repeat it n times
so the the value of the game uh
diminishes exponential
but the basis of the exponent is 1 minus
Delta squared and not one minus Delta so
the upper bound is due to Rao and it's
known to be tied due to an example by
runras also on the hot cycle game so
these two cannot be improved and but for
the case of small set expanders again
it's possible you pay something in in
the parameters of the small set
expansion but
the two disappears
so the value of the game becomes 1 minus
Delta instead of one minus Delta squared
to the power of n and things that depend
on Epsilon and Gamma again it follows
from the spectral approach but uh
the the new proofs uh are at least more
Elementary if they're not more intuitive
or simpler and hopefully they can be
extended to settings for which where the
spectral approach doesn't work or it's
too complicated
so summer to summarize it's sometimes
useful to project the sdp into a low
dimensional space uh into a constant
dimensional space for a small constant
and do then do around in using low
dimensional geometry
and and perhaps those ideas can be
combined with sum of squares to get new
results that were not previously known
so maybe those approaches are less
independent on the specific
semi-definite structure than the
spectral ones
and perhaps for specific ideas it might
be interesting to look into whether
sparse's cut problem can be improved
with this approach so thank you for
listening and I'll see you at the
conference